- My name is Jonathan Mannegut,
AKA JT, alias Joey Knuckles,
alias, Nicholas Scratch.
Nicholas Scratch 'cause
I don't accept pennies
and nickels, period.
Bad luck, financial deterrent,
I don't fuck with them.
A funny story how I ended up
down here on Skid Row actually.
I used to have a five bedroom house,
three cars in the driveway.
I had a classic '39 that was missing...
It was a classic '39 Plymouth.
It was missing one door handle.
Everything else was completely
original down to the straw
in the seats was still the same.
It was the car that my
father drove out here
from Hayneville, Alabama.
He came out to L.A. looking for work.
And I had a house fire.
Well, actually somebody broke in my house
and set it on fire while
I was in Victorville
visiting my kids.
As I explained to you all, I have 15 kids,
13 boys, two girls.
And I was on my way up
to go see my son's mother
and as I was getting ready
to leave, I got a call
at 6 in the morning talking
about it was a fire at the house.
Now mind you, it is a
big, big, big, big house.
So I'm thinking it's a
little bitty, something went
in the kitchen or something
burned in a trash can
and one wall or the curtain
or something is burnt up.
I said, well, what did y'all burn?
And they like, "No, the whole house."
I said, the whole house?
Now mind you, I'm riding the Greyhound,
then I screamed so loud I
woke up everybody on the bus,
'cause I'm like, how the
fuck did you burn down
a $2.5 million home?
How the fuck do you do that,
you know what I'm saying?
And they was like, "We was gone.
"We went to the club, we came home
"and the fire department was here."
And that was my spiral downwards.
- [Mark] That was how many years ago?
- 10
- [Mark] 10 years ago.
- 10 years ago.
I went from making five
to seven grand a week
(JT snaps)
to nothing, instantly.
All my recording studio
equipment, burnt, crispy.
- [Mark] You were making money how?
- I owned a recording
studio built at my house.
I used to work, me and my cousin, Binky,
me and Binky Womack, we
worked on a lot of tunes.
And plus, I had my own
fair share clientele.
Of course, my cousin, seeing
he got the Womack last name,
he had the higher echelon coming in,
but he still always managed
to make sure I had plenty of work.
So like I said, went from making
about five, seven grand a week to nothing,
to a hotel voucher from
what's the people, Red Cross,
to that, meaning it was
devastating because at the time,
my son's mother, Ramona,
was pregnant at the time.
I think she was about eight
months at the time, too.
And it was a horrible,
horrible experience.
It really was and it stripped
me of everything I had in me
because I've never done
really anything other
than graffiti, deejay
and music at that point.
That was it, I had been recording music
professionally since 16.
So here I was now with no
studio, no equipment, no house.
I ended up having to sell my classic car
and I couldn't get the price I wanted.
Like I said, my girl was
pregnant at the time.
I couldn't have us in the
streets, so I ended up selling
what should've went for
50, 60,000 for $1,000
because that was the
only offer I was getting,
so I took that.
That money was gone in
about two weeks or so,
two, three weeks.
And from that, it was couch
to this, couch to that.
Then eventually, we separated.
I ended up in a child custody
battle type shit situation
with children services on some fugazi shit
that didn't have shit to do with me,
everything with the mama,
nothing to do with me.
That put a whole nother toll on me
'cause now my kids are
living with my sister.
Me and my sister haven't got
along since my father died.
I've always admired my sister,
love my sister to death,
did everything she ever told me
'cause she was like a second mother to me,
but once my father had passed away,
the house that I was
living in, she was like,
"We're gonna turn this into a frat house."
I'm like, what about me and my kids?
"Y'all can find somewhere else to go."
Like, what you mean we can
find somewhere else to go?
I'm like, I'm the one that
took care of this man.
I watched him pissing blood
(phone ringing)
and going through everything
he was going through.
I ain't even worried about that phone.
Let that phone ring, man.
It can't be that important, man.
And so, like I said, I
watched my father deteriorate.
Now, this was a man who used
to could tighten car bolts
on tires with his bare
hands at the grocery store
and drive all the way home and
never have to touch it again.
He was just always this
big buff burly dude.
And it's funny because he
worked right down the street
at the Greyhound.
- [Mark] Oh yes.
- 37 years, he worked for them.
He had two years of vacation
time and one year of sick leave
at that point, when you get
37, and we all begged him
to take it, take it, take it.
Just take the next three years off
and just collect your
check and then retire,
but he ain't really want it.
He wanted to work.
And they found the quick
ass way to fire him
because my father couldn't read and write
when he first came to work for Greyhound.
He had to teach himself over the years.
So when they computerized everything,
because he had done got
old, eyes had got bad
'cause my father would
weld without the mask.
That was just the only way he could do it.
He couldn't do it with the mask on.
He had to do it with the mask off.
So his eyes was damaged so bad
that it wasn't much he could do.
So they had to put him in a tool shed.
And once they put him in
a class to teach him how
to computer and work the
computer, he fucked it all up
and didn't press I guess
whatever button you're supposed
to press to log out that he
had passed out the material,
so they fired him.
Said he passed out a million
dollars worth of material
and has no way to account for it.
Cut him short of his pension,
everything he had coming.
Broke my father's heart.
So after all of this had passed,
I finally patched things up
with my son's mother.
I dealt with my loss.
I didn't have no insurance.
So it was nothing I could
do to rebuild the house.
I tried to salvage what I could.
And it's funny because the
only thing that really survived
the fire was I had one
wall in my dining room
that was all obituaries,
my uncle, my great grandfather, my father.
All important people in my life.
That was the only thing survived.
It didn't even burn.
That one wall did not burn.
Everything else was destroyed.
And I had worked it out with
my son's mother, the new one,
Ramona, and I had moved in with her.
Actually, first, I moved to Victorville
where I met a excellent
brother named Mark Sykes.
Gave me a job out of
no motherfucking where.
I just was walking down the
street and he stopped me
and asked me did I want a job.
I mean, like the dream shit you imagine,
like nobody ever does that.
And he helped me get my
little bit of confidence back.
And then he even built a
recording studio up there
in Victorville and I ran it for him.
But that went south after so many months
because of whatever technical
difficulties he was having.
But I ends up moving to Riverside
because I was having a small problem,
not even really a problem.
I had got threatened
from my other baby mama
and she's no joke, you
know what I'm saying?
(JT laughs)
So I was slightly scared to go home
and so I ended up leaving
with my other son's mother
and out to Rialto and then we
ended up moving to Riverside.
And I was there for
awhile up until the point
where I realized that it
wasn't working with us.
I was gonna make myself miserable.
But this is me having my own anxiety
from not being in my own house.
I'm still suffering from that
loss inside, plus my sister
and father had just died two
months apart from each other.
I forget exactly how it happened,
but I ended up back with
my son's mother, Pierre.
That was holding some weight.
She was really ready
to break away from me,
but she had so much love for me
that she wouldn't just let
me be outside like that.
So I wasn't fully homeless yet.
And then me and her had a
daughter, our daughter Xanobia,
Xanobia Joyce Mannegut.
If you ever get to see
this, you know I love you
and I miss you
and I wish I'd never let
your mama take you to Texas.
My son's mother and my
daughter's mother explained to me
that she had found a way for her
to get some Section 8 housing
through one of these
homeless shelters down here.
Now, at this time, I'm living in Riverside
because no woman really wants her son
to be away from his father.
If they plan on bringing
him up any kind of manly way
to where he can understand
about what a man is supposed
to do and not supposed to do,
proper etiquette and whatnot.
And I'm staying with
her, up there with her,
with my daughter's mother and
then she tells me she wants
to send the baby to Texas to
stay with her mother for awhile
and me and her go into this program
over it was the Union
Rescue Mission at the time
and get some housing and
all of this extra, extra.
I really didn't understand
it and when I came down here
to look because my father who
worked down here for 37 years
told me he never wanted me downtown,
gave me horror stories about
it, how you'll get snatched
in the alley, head cut off,
this that and the other,
all my life.
So when I get here, I see
all these people moving
on the sidewalk and I'm look at this,
it's like a crowd of bums and hobos.
It's like a riot, you
know what I'm saying?
I'm real uncomfortable, I'm
edgy, but at the same time,
I know I'm a big dude,
I can handle myself.
I don't like to fight because
I tend to go overboard.
So I don't like to fight
at all, but I was leery
and I had my other son,
Roland, with me at the time
and he was horrified.
And I'm telling him, calm
down, man, calm down.
Don't worry about nothing,
just stay with me.
Ain't nobody gonna bother you.
And I ended up, I couldn't
find her that day.
So then I took him on
home, back out to Riverside
and then I came back out with my daughter
and we met right over by
the Union Rescue Mission
and she got inside the program
and all this other little stuff
and then she ended up
sending my daughter out.
When she sent my daughter out,
I went back out to Riverside.
I would stay down here
all week and then go home
on the weekend, which
eventually began to wear thin
with my mother-in-law out there.
And then the woman I
was with started dating
a whole nother dude and da-da, da-da, da.
You know how it goes.
If you ain't there, somebody
else is gonna fill your shoes.
So now I'm downtown permanently.
And so I'm thinking temporarily
it's gonna be about six weeks.
Six weeks turned into seven years.
And needless to say of course me
and my baby mother broke up again.
And anyway, she decided she was
gonna take all her anger out
on me for when we originally broke up
when the fire had happened,
which was three years prior.
And sent my daughter out to Texas.
I haven't seen her since
she was about nine months.
I have a picture, though, I do believe
is her currently right now.
She was staying with her
grandmother and her uncle, David,
David Richard Wilson.
Then time goes by and
I hear from her mother
that David has to take
my daughter to the doctor
and she had a boil or
some shit, da-da-da-da,
and then I get a call that
they took my daughter.
And I'm like, who?
Child services in Texas.
Now mind you, this is my
second time in child services
in Los Angeles with an open case
and child service case now
going on with her grandmother.
Turns out, my son's, no...
My baby mother's brother
had been raping my daughter
since she had got there.
Now, he was maybe 23, 24, 25 years old.
He gave my daughter
herpes, chlamydia and HIV.
- [Mark] And what age is she?
- Two, when she was finally diagnosed.
And Texas laws--
- [Mark] This is in Texas.
- This is in Texas.
Texas laws, you don't
have to take a blood test.
If they come in and say
they wanna inspect everybody
and take everybody and
make them take this test,
you don't have to do it.
So they never prosecuted
him in the beginning.
They, her mother, turned
around and tried to say
my daughter was born with
it, which fucked me up
because I hurried up and
called the social worker
and said she is a motherfucking lie.
And then I ran down
here to the JWCH clinic,
me and her mama, both took
HIV tests and had the hospital
send the children people
the results and everything.
I told them, I said, see,
they lying to you out there.
I say, and whoever was around
my daughter, whoever did it,
I said, they doing it to
the rest of them kids, too,
in their circle.
You need to test all of
the kids she play with
and see who it is.
But her brother refused to take
this test in the beginning,
like, that's my niece,
how the fuck you gonna say
that's my niece, I did that shit?
But it turns out his
girlfriend's daughter,
he was doing the same thing to her,
making her hop the fence
at school and fuck him
in the truck, in his car and
then climb back over the gate.
She went into the doctor.
- [Mark] How old is she?
- 12, pregnant, herpes, chlamydia, HIV.
That's when they swooped
down and grabbed him
'cause she said that she had been sleeping
with her mother's boyfriend.
And that's when they arrested him.
You can Google that and
you'll see for yourself,
you'll see the man, they
even showing pictures
of my daughter or whatever,
but that destroyed me
because I didn't know how to handle that.
I had a lot of rage in
me, I wanted the man dead,
still want him dead.
Matter fact, he's in the
Texas penitentiary system now.
All of my family that's
in jail right now in Texas
are looking for him.
And they all doing 16 years or better.
So they don't even care
if they get more time
for finding him because you just don't
ruin a child's life like that.
She will never have a normal life,
she can never have a decent boyfriend.
How many people you know is gonna
in school people won't
allow your daughter to play
with them, what if she
fall and scrape her knee
and then it's a lot to that
and I didn't know how to handle that, man.
Taking medicine for the rest of your life
from the age of two, I
didn't know how to handle it.
I didn't, so I let them go ahead
and put her up for
adoption, which I regret.
I regret, but there
was nothing I could do.
I was out here sleeping in a tent,
I had no place for her to go.
My mother at this time had all of my kids.
I already had four of
my boys at her house.
I couldn't overload her.
I had no money to get to Texas.
Plus, I was in the
middle of a case myself.
So I tried to work things out
with my son's mother once again.
She's feeling worse than me, though,
because it's her brother,
you know what I'm saying?
But in all, I still feel
like they protected him.
Even though she was 100% with
no, my daughter's mother,
I couldn't believe her mother had made up
that bullshit ass story
to try to save this
weirdo's motherfucking life
who needed to be in the
penitentiary anyway.
They ended up giving him a life sentence.
Still think he should have
got the death penalty,
but I don't know.
I guess Texas don't do that.
- [Mark] They do.
- The lady who had been keeping her
had the same name as my daughter.
And I just felt like she was gonna be able
to handle the situation better than me.
And it's a trip because her
and my son, Angel, have the same birthday.
December 16th, both born on the same.
So it fucks his birthday up for me,
but I manage to get through it.
But I know at that point I'm holding in
a lot, a lot of pain.
And I search the internet
and type in Xenobia's
birthday party every year.
And this year, I finally
got a picture of her
at her birthday party.
The lady who adopted her, same
lady who was caring for her,
changed her name, which
really fucked me up some more.
But she was happy, she was smiling.
I know she don't remember me
because she was only seven,
nine months the last
time I got to see her.
And so now, I'm going through
all this, all of this stress
and I'm trying to be a man about it
and seem like I'm not feeling it.
In reality, I'm drinking
close to 18 beers a day
'cause at that point,
I couldn't have no weed
or nothing like that
'cause of child services,
even though I had a marijuana license
because of my back and shoulder.
And I just sat out there on
the sidewalk until I met...
Well, I like to call her
she was like my savior.
A young lady by the name of
Jazz, she gave me purpose again.
But like most things, nothing ever lasts.
And she found out that she
wasn't totally deserved
the pedestal I was putting
her on at the time.
But still, she got me closer to God,
I began to forgive myself
and she gave me purpose.
I helped her get on her feet,
off of Skid Row, working,
I encouraged her in everything she does,
she works in Beverly Hills now.
She gets to wear a
dress to work every day.
Nice hairdos, everything
you could possibly want.
Everything that she had
wanted in the beginning.
And we separated and
that's when I met Precious,
who's probably either across the street
or up in one of these buildings,
instead of down there
driving me fucking insane.
And so I had to leave her alone.
But I watched her go from
in and out of addiction,
in and out of addiction.
She would usually if she relapsed,
it would only last two, three days.
And then she would be
like I wanna go home,
I'm gonna get high, please
take me home and da-da.
And I paid for the motel
that we was living in
for maybe a good three,
four years, $65 a day,
so that's like 1800 a month,
which makes no sense financially
because that's enough to
put me in any apartment,
but this is what I'm doing,
paying the day-to-day rent in a motel.
So my other child services case closes.
They send my kids to go
stay with their mother.
She had developed a habit
and I was telling my mother.
I remember I said, it's
some things you don't know.
I don't think she's quite ready yet.
Give her a few more months
to get herself together.
My mother does not believe it.
I've got to be the scoundrel, of course.
I'm lying and then whatever, whatever.
So send my kids to go stay with her.
She ends up getting them
tooken three months later
after they got back home.
She gets them tooken away again.
Now, I'm really distraught.
I ended up sending Precious
to go stay with her father
in Atlanta, which was
the best thing for her
'cause at that point,
she was smoking like a burning building.
She had done lost all the
weight, titties gone, ass gone.
She was just you could see
her teeth when she's talking,
that's just how much weight
was up out of her face.
And I had got me a motel back
on the other side of town,
started back speaking with
Jazz on a regular basis.
We weren't a couple, but
we was just good friends.
She was somebody I could talk to.
She was like I say she was my savior.
She got me through a lot
of rough mental pictures,
always had something kind to say.
And mind you, during all of this, though,
I'm still seeing my sons,
seeing my sons and trying
to get to the ones out that's
further away from the...
Four ended up in Virginia and
she was mad I never came back.
Four ended up in from Riverside
till now in Victorville.
Then I got another set
at my mother's house.
And she done kicked the
two oldest ones out.
So now they living in real
fucking foster care group homes.
And I have court on the
26th actually of this month.
So I came down here.
I started selling the
cigarettes, which I really hated
'cause you know I don't
like nickels and pennies,
but I did it.
- [Mark] When you say
cigarettes, you mean?
- Cigarettes, regular cigarettes.
- [Mark] Tobacco cigarettes?
- Regular tobacco cigarettes.
- [Mark] Okay.
And then the spice thing came,
which was really funny
because even though I hate
to admit this on camera, I'm gonna say it,
it probably never even
really have gotten as bad
as it is now if it wasn't for me
because they had already
banned it from all their shops
'cause they used to sell
these little $2 containers
down here and people were
buying them left and right.
My son's mother started smoking spice
because she couldn't smoke weed.
So that's when I noticed the connection.
And then it was a shop
that I knew of that had it.
And I went up there and they had some
and I know about three or
four shops that had it.
You see, at the time, I
would say I didn't know
that they had banned it
yet from out of the shops.
So I talked to the people
who I normally talk with.
I'm a great people's
person, excellent salesman.
And I ended up getting it $3 a bag.
After $3, you was making $45
for every $3 that you spent.
I think at the time, it was
only maybe one, two, three,
four, five people that
made up my little circle,
but I was the only one who
was getting in at that price.
And then every now and then,
it'd be as partner of mine
liked to call them, the basket people.
They go dumpster diving and
they find all of this stuff
and they need it resold but
it wasn't as popular yet.
And they would come and sell
us these bags that they'd find,
great big old shopping
carts full, 15, $20.
Oh wow, for real, all this?
"Yeah, here you go."
That's the magic number downtown, $10.
You can get anything for
$10 downtown from a woman
to a motherfucking refrigerator for $10
'cause nine times out of 10,
all they wanna do is get high
or if they're a heroin addict,
they just wanna get unsick
and $10 will do it.
So we ends up with I
mean I think we had a guy
who was selling us bags for a quarter
because he was a heroin
addict, it wasn't his thing
but he had so much of it
and he wouldn't tell us
where it was hid or nothing.
Another dude, the guy who was selling
big shopping carts full
ended up robbing him
because he wanted to have
the corner on the market.
And that's when it all began.
That's when I became
addicted to fast money.
But I have seen one joint sell for $20.
I've seen a bag sell for 100.
I've seen a guy come to
you and say, you know what?
I want 50 bags, I want 20 bags.
I've seen people spend their whole check.
And that's when I began to realize,
plus I had already realized
with my son's mother,
this shit was a serious fucking addiction.
I don't know what goes on
in that dream they have
when they nod out, but it's something
they don't never wanna come back from.
Just relight the joint.
And when they see it's about halfway gone,
they used to walk back over
to you and buy another one.
It was I seen how it worked.
It was too instant an addiction,
too instant an addiction,
especially for somebody
who wants to get high,
but can't get high, too
fast of an addiction.
And they almost get scary
to you because they act
just like how crackheads
used to act in the '80s.
They'll search the ground for roaches.
They'll get beat down in
the middle of the street
for picking up a joint out of somebody box
or take a chance and
just run with a handful
and get beat up real bad in
the street, I done seen it.
I done seen people try
and swim in a puddle.
I seen women strip butt
naked and run down,
up and down the street.
I seen women strip butt asshole naked
and take anyone to be your sex slave.
I done seen everything
happen off of that spice.
I seen them before fight God.
I got a funny one for you.
Scotty is an atheist.
Scotty smoked a spice joint
and swore the sky opened up
and God was talking to
him and he met Jesus.
And he ran up on everybody
and said, "He's real!"
(JT laughs)
"Do you see him, he's everywhere."
He said, "Every time I turned,
he was right fucking there."
And he said when the high came
down, he came back and said,
"I gotta get another joint so
I can finish talking to him."
Because spice I don't
know what it is about it,
but the high when you go right back
into the same dream again.
So as long as you can keep the high going,
you can keep the dream going.
And I seen people dream of everything
from being basketball
players, rappers on stage,
all kind of little shit,
and then you get the few
that get stuck in a nightmare.
Them the ones that be everywhere
and ambulance gotta come.
And then people started getting greedy.
The guy who was actually producing most
of what we were using to sell
came with a whole nother thing.
I wanna sell you a whole
key of this, 2.2 pounds.
I'm like, nah, a key?
Like, for real, like
dope, you selling a key?
Come on, now.
And he was like, "For real, $800."
Truth of the matter is,
I found out later on,
it don't cost but maybe
100 and something dollars
to make the whole key.
Then you got the next person doing it.
Now, this person, because
he doesn't have the issue
that the rest of us as
homeless on Skid Row do.
He's got a house, he's
already got dope money
and drug money.
He's got cocaine money,
crystal money, heroin money.
He's buying big.
Now he's getting three,
four, five of them.
He's on the corner chopping
your price in half now.
So now it's not $2 anymore, it's $1.
All because this greedy
person in the inner circle
decided to tell him that.
So of course now the money
starts to shorten up between us.
And we looking at them like,
man what are y'all doing?
This is supposed to be just us.
And to be honest with you, if
it would've stayed just us,
everybody'd probably be making about five,
six grand a day right now.
- [Mark] What is spice?
- Spice is it's basically marshmallow leaf
or what's the other one, plant?
It's called...
It's an aphrodisiac, too.
Damiana is another source.
It really can be anything 'cause
marshmallow leaf is nothing
but have you ever seen those
weeds that grow in your yard
in the winter and they have
this round leaf on them?
They'll pop up in any vacant lot you see.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure I've seen them.
- That's a marshmallow leaf.
So basically, you just got
a bag of lawn clippings,
all right, and you sort it out
to get the dirt up out of it
or whatever and then letting it dry.
And then you take that you
spray this chemical on it
and you let it dry.
And then you bag it.
Now, it's labeled as an incense,
which puts it in a whole nother category
because okay, it's not being advertised
as something you smoke.
People are just smoking it.
So how do you go about banning incense?
You can't really because Walmart sells it,
it's in every little shops
that got a scented candle
or this, this, that and the other.
It's just incense or tea
'cause they also make
it out of tea leaves.
They say it's tea, but
people are smoking it
and getting high off of it
because of what's sprayed on it.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's very addictive.
- Very addictive, very addictive.
Well, some people, one time
and that's it for them.
And they have that little
oh, this is too strong
because truthfully, I ain't gonna lie,
my son's mother was smoking it so much
and she would just nod out
and I said, man, what the fuck is this?
Shit cannot be that strong.
And mind you, at the time,
I'm still smoking weed
because our case had closed at that time.
The first one with my son,
other son out in Riverside,
that case had just closed.
So I'm smoking weed, she's
still smoking spice, though.
And I hit it two times.
This is the living room, that over there
where that blue tarp or whatever
it is, that's the kitchen.
It took me 45 minutes
to make my baby a bottle
'cause once it hits you,
it's not like a gradual upscale high.
It's bam, and you're right at the top.
To me, it felt like that feeling you get
when you drunk too much and you're like,
if I lean left or right, I'm gonna vomit.
That's how it felt to me.
I didn't like it at all.
And I ate some noodles and I laid down
in front of the front
door with the fan on,
trying to make the high come down.
Then I started hearing shit,
like I hear people plotting
on me outside the door.
And then when I open
the door, it's crickets.
Ain't nobody outside at all.
And I close the door, it start right back.
I open the door, it stop.
I close the door, it start right back.
So I opened the door, leave it open
and lay in front of the fan.
When that shit wore off of
me, I looked at her and said,
how in the fuck is this not illegal?
You got to be kidding me.
This needs to be illegal.
- [Mark] But you can see it on the street,
the people that are most
high, they're smoking spice.
- Nah, you know what?
That's really a combination
of mental illness
and the dream.
You remember I told you
they go into this dream?
Like I know a guy who just...
He's dead now, I just found this out.
This is before I came back.
I had left in January like I told you
because of what was going on.
And he was sitting in his
room smoking by himself
and I guess sometimes the
high will make you not know
where you are and you'll panic.
And he jumped out his
window, six stories up.
- [Mark] Died?
- Fucked me you when I heard it.
- [Mark] That happened here in San Pedro?
- That happened right here downtown.
- [Mark] Yeah, but on San Pedro street?
- No, right on Sixth Street in the SRO.
His name was Jerrell,
his name was Jerrell.
Used to be a dancer, that was his thing.
He wanted to be on Who Can Dance
or whatever that little show is.
That was his goal.
The second he started
smoking that shit, though,
pshaw, out the window.
He couldn't even function.
He would just be sitting there.
He couldn't move.
And he just swore he could
still do this and do that.
I said, but you can't, you sitting there
in this fucking spice coma all day, man.
And his whole thing doing it,
watched his woman leave
him, everything else.
He ended up by himself.
As long as he had spice,
he didn't give a fuck.
Spent his whole entire check up
and still get credit after that.
Kind of in the beginning to
me that was the best part
until I began to realize
what was going on.
'Cause it would be dudes
that'll owe you $750,
$800, $300, $400.
So when check days came and
you would have so much money
in your pocket, you wouldn't
even wanna sit out there
to sell nothing.
Like, I'm gone.
I'm going to go see my kids.
- [Mark] Was it tough
collecting on these guys?
- Nah.
- [Mark] How do you get them to pay up?
- With me, it was different because
for every joint you got on credit for me,
'cause I would charge $10 for
one joint on credit, period.
That was it 'cause I didn't wanna do it
because I had a motel bill I was paying,
plus I had child support and
all this other little shit.
I had the money to issue out.
So I never really wanted to do it.
But when they started agreeing to it,
I was like, are you sure about that?
I'm not gonna have to
hunt you down or nothing?
They was like, "No," I said, all right.
So you'll have a dude, he'll
credit 75 joints from you.
When he shows back up and
he pays the $750 to you,
I'll give him a whole
nother 75 joints for free
just for paying your bill.
So in his eyes, he
lightweight feel like he won
because now I got way more spice
that I didn't even know he
was gonna give me these 50,
40 extra joints, so he's happy.
Yeah, but what happens?
He smokes one, falls asleep,
wakes up and his friends
that was sitting there around him
took everything else from him.
And I think at that point,
I think the most I ever made
was I think 1200 and that
was really bizarre to me,
scared the shit out of me
because it was $1 joints
and 1200 times, I went hand to
hand, 1200 times in one day.
And that's when it became
people started making their own spice,
which was absurd because they
only knew two ingredients.
They didn't know the third ingredient.
So you got guys who was
putting nail polish remover
on marshmallow leaf
'cause you can buy a key
of marshmallow leaf 7,
$8 for the whole key.
And you get nail polish remover for $3
and you soak the whole batch
and then they're putting
formaldehyde, spray that on.
This is what made that
triage happen down there
where they had filled up
all these emergency rooms
and had 15 people, had
to open one in the middle
of the street in San Pedro.
And 15 people died behind that
and the dude that had
it, kept on selling it.
He kept on selling it.
Now, those who were hardcore smokers,
we call them black fingers
'cause they had black fingertips
from smoking roaches down.
I mean, black, black, black.
I mean, blue-black, like
that, burnt up meat really.
(JT laughs)
And those cats were okay.
They were just as strong as
hell, but those who weren't
at that level, had that tolerance level,
they were dropping off left and right.
Then it was people who was
going until they went home
to smoke and nobody was there to save them
or call an ambulance for them
while they was in the SROs.
And so they just recently gave the guy,
I think they gave him 30 years
when they pinned it all on him.
But I had been telling
everybody for the longest
after that had happened
that it was a federal crime.
Y'all thinking that y'all coming
out here and y'all sitting
in front of the police
rolling joints, I mean all up
and down the street, y'all
just sitting there rolling
these joints like you're
not gonna go to jail.
It's a federal crime.
And then I had met this guy
named Joe and Joe introduced me
to this young white guy who
was about maybe 26 I think,
26, he had been in business three years,
made $40 million.
- [Mark] Selling?
He was a manufacturer and distributor.
He had the warehouse.
- [Mark] How much?
- 40 million, three years,
had a house in Calabasas,
Ferrari, Rolls-Royces.
He used to take G5 flights.
I've seen their order list.
Their order list would come.
It'd be 8,000, 10,000, 12,000,
700 here, 800 there.
It was amazing the money
that was coming to him,
hand over fist, and he
was shocked, too, himself.
But whenever they came up
with a law to say, okay,
we're banning this chemical,
can't use this anymore,
it's illegal, federally banned now.
So now you can't have that.
But if you're a manufacturer
and distributor,
you own this company, business
license, registered warehouse
and everything, the
government sends you a paper
that says this chemical is now banned.
For a substitute you can use,
and they'll give three to five things.
- [Mark] They tell you what to use.
- Yeah, but this guy,
like I said, it was
very lucrative for him.
He was abiding by all the
rules the state of California
said to him, but his orders
were coming from out of state
and other states were
having the same issue, too.
A lot of people didn't know it
because it was like they
were keeping it under wraps.
But I think about all 50 states
now have an issue with it.
And so you got a company in Detroit,
they want $8,000 worth of product
because they doing so well out there.
They spend they $8,000.
You got a company in Florida,
they wanna spend $20,000.
You got these people over
here in Des Moines, Idaho,
they got 50,000 they wanna spend.
So money is coming to
him, left, hand over foot,
hand over feet from legal tobacco shops
that are selling the spice
and he's a legal producer of the shit,
but his flaw was chemicals
that are banned in California
that you bought the ones you
can use, don't necessarily mean
they're not banned in another state.
So he's mailing the
stuff out to the people,
just conducting business as usual.
And they came and raided the warehouse,
snatched him out his house in Calabasas,
froze his bank accounts, arrested him
and told him he was
under arrest for the sale
and distribution of synthetic
marijuana for spice.
And he was like, that's
impossible, man, I run the factory.
I'm legally federally licensed
to do this, this, that and
the other, this is bullshit!
So when he go to court, they
tell him, the deal is 20 years.
He was like, 20 years?
I'm not doing 20 years!
Mind you, he's 23 years
old, no, 26 at the time.
23 is when he opened the company,
26 years old at the time.
And he's like, Hell no, I'm legal.
I'm not doing...
He goes and hires him
the best lawyer he can
and everything else,
but it was nothing he could do about it.
So he fought the case.
And everything he was trying
to say that he was going to use
for his defense failed against him.
So they ended up giving him
30 years in the federal pen.
Stripped him of all his money,
all his cars, everything, gone.
And like I say, I took a
hiatus for three months
because it was I was going
through too much mentally.
I wasn't getting along with
any of my kids' mothers anymore
because it was like somebody
started undercutting
my business at the time.
And it was a gentleman that I've known
for more than 10 years.
At one point, he was even
taking care of my kids for me.
Cut into my money really
bad, so I went from making
about $800 a day to making $100 a day.
And it really affected me.
And one of my mentors from
childhood that knows both of us
and he told me the best
way as he possibly could.
He said, "It's a sidewalk.
"You can't stop what
goes on on a sidewalk,
"you can't claim anything
'cause it's not yours."
I said it's fucked up that
your friend is the one
that's doing this to you.
He said, "But, now you
know he's not your friend.
"So you have a choice to make yourself.
"You say, do you do something
that's gonna cause bad vibes
"and retaliation to yourself
"or do you just continue to be you?"
I tell him, I'm gonna continue to be me.
So I got well.
This caused rifts between
me and my son's mother
because they was agreeing,
now they finally all agreed
to bring my kids to my
mother's house every weekend.
And kids was all getting brand new stuff,
everything that they needed.
I was like I was a good father once again.
Even though what I was doing
wasn't completely legal
or illegal at the time
'cause they hadn't made that
law up yet, I was at peace.
And then that got snatched from me.
And I fell behind in my child support.
Baby mother's not understanding.
Why I didn't do this, why I didn't do that
and I'm just trying to tell
them, y'all don't understand,
I don't wanna be here no more.
I just want some peace.
I need to do what I wanna do.
My two friends had just passed away
and I was sitting there and
I was thinking to myself,
I really been on this corner
almost, downtown period,
about six, seven years that
I could have really just
the same struggle I did,
I could've went to college
and had my degree and
then two years on the job
that I had trained for.
And then that's when I
realized I had a conversation
with my mother and she was like,
"I'm 77 years on my birthday
"that I don't wanna be
in California no more.
"I wanna go back to Alabama."
She said, "But I can't
'cause I got your kids."
And that's when I said I
gotta get myself back reunited
with my mother.
And I spent that time around my mother
until she finally looked at me and said,
"Don't you think you might wanna go out
"and sell some dope, do something
other than be right here?"
And I had to take it
for what it was worth.
I mean, she dealt with me for a month,
during the cold rainy part of the winter.
She said I rose her
electricity bill up to $700
fucking with them floor heaters.
You know that shit'll do it to you.
And I ended up right back
down here all over again.